[Music]
on this one we put numbers to all
there's some trees in here
[Music]
you hungry for broccoli - hmm
oh my God look how much food he leaves
him on Saturday he ate through one piece
of chocolate cake one ice cream cone one
pickle slice of Swiss cheese a piece of
salami
[Music]
let's begin hungry you ready for your
food you hungry
[Music]
toothless pH did you renew the car
insurance no I thought you were gonna do
that we talked about this last night
well I never said I was gonna do it
your whiting me out I'm not winding you
up why would you think that you always
do this
why is it always left up to me why do I
feel like the only adult in this
relationship you're at home all day long
with nothing to do and you can't even do
this one simple thing to help me out
[Music]
did you renew the car insurance before
we get into that if you like a glass of
wine
sure Savion profitable yes please you
want me to put some food on this one yes
please
yes some pasta how does that sound that
would be great
I'm sorry I didn't do conch Wednesday no
body's just been a handful I think you
didn't get mostly yesterday he was just
the morning attention you know I brought
him food he threw stray on the floor No
thank you whoa no no can't be easy with
buddy all day he can be a handful
he should cut each other some slack no
one in this house gets a sleeping
[Music]
which means they can like the teddy
my pity
[Music]
please do comment like and subscribe and
take a look at our shop for more from
the School of Life
you